hello their rejection I'm Greg Alva this
is do be a lady watch corridor cruise
VFX artist react to resurrected actors
bad and great CG Cooper's actually
taught me that the first time she saw
corridor crew's video was because she
watched the reaction I did actually uh
yes oh my god what a easy way to segue
here Cooper is the star of the short
film that I was in civil defense Red
Rover she did an incredible job in it
the short film came out great
I don't promote everything I've ever
been a part of because this one turned
out wonderful Cooper did an excellent
job everyone raves about her in it go
check out that short film as soon as you
can a lot of hard work went into it yes
and this guy is incredible
like what I just couldn't three-minute
no you're so your eyes and everything
yes I told you it's like I know I you
know I loved working with you and the
whole team it was it was good squash so
check it out no but yeah yeah primarily
great anyway we have some thoughts on
the whole resurrection actor thing but
we'll save that for after the after the
video
[Music]
that's right she died in serranos people
have been doing their owners reacting to
things really into their line of work
now we're a bunch of visual effects
artists and today we're going to react
to deceased actors one of the most
challenging things you can do in visual
effects is making photo realistic human
look this videos from June guys that's a
little bit over in terms of trying to
replicate a person that no longer is
alive this is the best that has ever
been done it was pretty good footage the
only thing that gives it away is if you
watched his neck in the collar of his
shirt the way his body moves doesn't
correspond to how his head the clarity
is really high movie where Paul Walker
was completely computer-generated like
the next oh really
actually Paul Walker's brothers they
look like that they use it as
inspiration for the performance
reference for the lighting whoa yeah I
had no idea it's such a normal situation
so it doesn't trigger anything to be
looking for your text that's crazy
what's really good all really good the
only did smiley put is
like the shadows and like it goes like
this they don't quite have those fold
just pull out you don't really notice it
I had no idea they did any of that on
the movie iris in your lens are like
different levels and so when light comes
in from the side of your eye it catches
your iris so that means that the artists
have modeled the internals of the eye
and the iris has actual depth of the
eyes it's really hard to identify what
exactly is off here but our brain after
millions of years of evolving to
identify faces can identify that
something is awesome it's perfect man
muscles flex like watch you only really
notice it if you're looking fear yeah
yeah what a digital is probably the most
talented visual effects studio in the
world in terms of trying to replicate a
person that no longer is alive this is
the best that has ever been done
wrong solicitor he went long I've ever
seen oh yeah it feels wrong this is like
Tekken 7 right here dude dummy
[Music]
that's what I was gonna say - his skin
looks - plasticky or wax yeah we have a
flashlight here I'd show you he was here
though do it on the back of my ear you
know what I'm talking about where your
skin lights up kind of like red that
happens across your face your arm it
absorbs light scatters it the skin
itself is actually kind of
self-illuminating and here it just
sucked I didn't know that subsurface
scattering effect so it kind of comes in
crosses like it's just a reflective
plastics your face there's a little bit
so I can see what's happening is the
lights actually going in in a slightly
reddish like edge between the skin where
it's bright and where it's dark and his
brow yeah that I live and this cheek
there's two nuns that slightly reddish
tint that little reddish line there's
the perfect example of that red line of
social service a terrific like that's
what I'm talking about where it's not
about the single to see through things
it's also writing the edge of where the
light disappears because you have a
little of that light that's actually
gone into the surface that's now
catching that that shadow right there if
you want it to be real especially when
you do high key lighting like this you
need to model that and that's very
complicated cuz it getting two years
skeleton underneath your face it's gonna
block the light a lot better this one
right here because cuz you're hiding
detail you know you're you're you're
kind of hiding it but the other ones is
like you go real extreme on the lighting
it does a lot to hide your flaws
okay I've never watched it I want to see
if I can identify her neck is so right
dude
maybe they knew she was gonna pass like
real quick let's loop in the green
screen up do the papaya green screen by
our Hospital
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
right like it's me chill let me gather
those assets before you know a lot of
the gladiator movie or an actor dies
before the movie finishes production and
they still have scenes to shoot with him
this is just a collage cutting out of
one shot oh I never does that
no for an older movie yeah here we go
okay yep
so peter cushing is the actor who died
some time ago the only reason why they
are able to reproduce him digitally in
this movie was because they actually had
a perfect life cast of his face oh and
they just that was us pure luck on their
part that looks fake so they're able to
take a very high detailed 3d scan oh no
so that's it so yeah I mean digitally
the lighting is great the lighting is
very good they're doing all the things
I've been saying with Lighting's like a
strong side key light good contrast
all the technical checklists are being
checked off here why doesn't why doesn't
it look at yeah I think it looks really
bad in my opinion I can't really stands
out no I do too there's no looks like a
video game and it's really hard to
replicate that yeah you can tell that
it's not real it's an animated and dummy
whip it's just it's hard to say what
have they not yet done to take it that
final step this is basically the best we
can do it's not yet looks when it's
still looks perfect it's the small
things that happen in your face when big
things happen like my go you know the
big thing is my job opens up and you see
that the small things that happen are my
hairs change direction like Michael
wrinkles really in just rude notice I
started doing anything two weeks if
someone asked me to do this I wouldn't
know where to start
it'd be like the equivalent of like
someone bang hey and you got the desert
and like put all these little pieces of
sand in order I need a little better
very very good does not buy you
something so you can still tell yeah it
looks really good and like how did they
do this or anyone see like the makeup
texture for have your eyes well yeah
which is the person they had down to
detail that's a boy this is hyper
sharper than high-resolution yeah I feel
I get some micro movement
reason rise like soul is because she's
not she's not people aren't just a
physical it's also the personality this
is somebody to side by side that was
when she's confronting lord Vader at the
very beginning of a motion capture they
can do with deep fake do you believe
people should own the likeness of I can
stick Tom Cruise in a corridor video
right now I leave something that looks
like a cruise I would be able to say
it's Tom Cruise me Tom Cruise beeline I
can have something that looked exactly
like Tom Cruise
should he be upset can he sue me for his
likeness do we own our own all these if
you have a movie a TV show a music video
and you want us to break down leave a
comment below we had a bunch of great
suggestions we made a huge list so far
and you're going through we're going to
knock them out so please leave a comment
we read them all
[Laughter]
yeah you don't look like they're making
a movie where they're putting James Dean
in it and I'm hundred percent against it
dude same too
I think what they said the last moment
was exactly what hit it yeah was that
it's not the performer it's not the
performer it looks like them but I think
what's hard is like you know James Dean
died and what the 50s there is no way he
was ever gonna know that technology was
gonna lead us to a place like he didn't
even get to have a choice of like no
don't reanimate myself because who
thought that would be possible I think
it's disturbing by the fact that it's
the secondary lead well yeah what they
did with Walker like if you have these
unfortunate situations of a Paul Walker
dying whether they're almost died
filming or with The Sopranos after Stein
and you need to fill this in that's a
completely different situation so
different like that's acceptable yeah I
feel like it's like you got to finish
the film I think they probably would be
yeah finish it out because like what's
the alternative just scrap it yeah good
like and a double can look yeah more
than when it's clearly not that because
yeah like the Paul Walker moments the
only time I looked out for it was that
final moment which by the way every time
makes me boss it's the other moments in
the movie I'm like oh I didn't realize
that it was like yeah that's me I think
is fine it can still be some controversy
right I get it but for me personally I'm
like whatever so dude when it comes to
this whole Jean scene situation that was
the first time I read the whole article
and then hearing the quotes of how they
were saying like we were looking through
the archive or looking through who we
can cast and realized one James Dean and
then the the company saying like weak
now we can have access to all of our
clients as if these decisions are like
our ally
now like know you that is it is
disturbing and also I think it's
insulting to all the countless actors so
they could have auditioned I think
you're tampering with legacy at that
point I don't think it'll ruin his
legacy but I think you are terrible I
think what's really messed up especially
it's just like part of the performance
is the actor making those choices in the
moment and yeah their decision and when
you're CGI in them you're taking away
that choice of there's like it's not
really them making those choices and
that's where they're like genius comes
from and they're amazing acting and like
you can't just have someone animate that
big this is what they do and they're
gonna be great and good it's just like
that's not like it's just you can't take
that choice away it's it's not authentic
I think it's disturbing to when it's
like it's an original film or whatever
they're doing and it's not like they're
gonna put the character James Dean as
James Dean no they're putting it's an
actor pretending to be James Dean as a
different character I'm like what like
with the rogue one these actors I had
already played them so I get why they
attempted it yeah fast and furious to
say it you know it just goes back to
like me want to make money and these
people have clout and so we're gonna use
their name to like continue making money
off that like it like you know if they
try to do that to freakin Robin Williams
oh god I will cry because you just can't
he was a brilliant beautiful human being
yeah such and and to take him and try to
create that kind of charisma I'm so so
against it's it's sad it's this
hardening and you and to say like no
it's James Dean and I'm like no it's an
it's someone pretending to be James Dean
who is that's not to be a character who
like you are kidding you're sorry I just
I really feel like it's just such a it's
it's a total marketing but what it
worries me about that is often times I
think a lot of us will have like a
morbid curiosity where we're gonna go in
like cynical and not liking it but we're
gonna check it out because we're guys
mercurial yeah but I think by us going
to go check it out people exactly
they're gonna be like admit it made
money it got it got people so keep do
keep doing more let's get other deaf
actors to be in it yeah it's kind of
like with all these like remakes and
live actions or people are like we're
sick
remix we're sick of live actions like
remakes and all that but it's like but
you're but by going to still see him
you're supporting yeah them continuing
that model it's kind of like honestly
with YouTube they don't care about what
gets likes or dislikes it's just that
it's watch that watch there's an agent
yeah there you go
so they're like oh that's all they can
you actor step in have a good time no
but like part of the fine is new people
have you have you seen any of the
Godfather films okay so in the Godfather
- they have a young Marlon Brando in and
it was Robert De Niro they cast and
Robert De Niro what Oscar for it right
but nowadays I feel like they would just
have had it De Niro you wouldn't have a
crush you can use it like it just does
it
no and I feel like it's special I think
James Dean is especially though because
he had three films and he died early yes
but that's part of what made his legacy
so long-lasting is man the what if he
had been around like that pondering
actually legacy but then now you're
putting James Dean in a movie and I'm
like no so I just context of all this is
different it's like finishing a movies
one thing but then yeah
casting okay let's bring back Walter
Matthau or Marley right there charm and
charisma comes from them not the
computer like W doing that to Marilyn
Monroe like CGI her it's like really
great I'll see what I started like she
wouldn't be the same icon if she was
just like a computer-generated being no
I just don't I don't think it's there's
the same relatability it's like why
you're gonna have them going promo tours
exactly but it's good it's like it's a
black mayor episode the Miley Cyrus no
way they're like happening go ahead
scares me when black mayor starts
becoming true and you're like watch it
and you're like yeah I know buddy freaks
me out cuz you're like well we're so
close yeah and I still feel that they
got a ways to go because I like what Oh
text oh isn't that like it's so Lux fake
it like
it's something in the eyes you can
always tell how matter how good it is
yes like I actually I just saw this
maybe the Irishman and D H DeNiro in it
and all the D aging on everyone looks
wonderful I couldn't tell what Al Pacino
and Joe Pesci but there are times with
DeNiro where I'm like parent yeah so
like D Aging's one thing but man because
you're still there at least they're
using their based faiths yeah yes
they're still perform and it's their
performance they're just like what makes
a performance unique and personality
unique is the person in computer because
then it just becomes a formula at that
point yeah really frustrating it's like
let's do it which is our movie today
everything is just production line cold
cut it's got to be this this is what
makes money and then it's like where's
the discovery where's the new stories
anyway subscribe to corner crew as soon
as you can
Paula Cooper carded them on Instagram
and Twitter
she needs followers sure that's all she
cares that's just the kind of
performance she gives a good short
fellow yeah check it out great physical
comedy they're very slapstick
subscribers a real reason
look that notification will catch you
guys soon